[Musique]
et cette revue de presse est avec Hélène
frad ce matin à la Une Hélène et bien il
y a cette visite forcément depuis hier
de la première ministre Elisabeth borne
en Algérie une visite pour concrétiser
cette réconciliation qui a été amorcée
cet été par Emmanuel Macron présenté
comme une visite de travail par Helmut
Jahid se déplacement a pour objectif je
cite de développer les potentialités
exceptionnelles des relations
franco-algériennes le Journal officiel
qui monteront le voit la première
ministre Elisabeth borne tout sourire
aux côtés de son homologue algérien
aymède ben Abderrahman le Premier
ministre algérien qui salue lui la
nouvelle dynamique qui permettra
d'approfondir la concertation engagée
cet été par le président algérien
d'elmadji teboun et Emmanuel Macron qui
se sont d'ailleurs entretenues hier lors
d'un entretien téléphonique exprimez
leur satisfaction pour l'évolution
positive et le niveau
franco-algérienne je cite toujours que
de politesse et Elisabeth borne n'est
pas en reste dans une interview accordée
au site TSA Algérie la première ministre
souligne elle de son côté l'ampleur sans
précédent de la délégation ministérielle
qui l'accompagne le signe selon elle de
dynamisme de la richesse et de la
densité de la coopération entre Paris et
Alger et des bénéfices mutuels que l’une
et l'autre peuvent retirer d'une
relation plus étroite ou voilà donc
Hélène pour les déclarations officielles
mais concrètement à quoi va servir cette
visite c'est précisément la question que
pose le matin d'Algérie qui affirme
qu'aucun dossier stratégique n'est
officiellement prévu sur la table ni la
sécurité ni le dossier de l'énergie pas
un mot non plus sur la question des
violations des droits de l'homme
critique le journal qui regrette que les
300 détenus d'opinion et la mise entre
parenthèses de toutes les libertés
démocratiques ne soient pas la autorité
des Français le président français ne
voudrait pas ouvrir un nouveau front
gazier ironise le journal pas très
satisfait non plus que la question
mémorielle était renvoyée à une
commission mixte d'historien c'est connu
quand on veut éluder un problème en lui
crée une commission du côté de la presse
française libération évoque une Algérie
de retour sur le devant de la scène
internationale un pays qui fait partie
des plus gros producteurs de gaz
mondiaux et qui se retrouvent de plus en
plus courtisé plus courtisé que jamais
depuis la guerre en Ukraine évidemment y
compris par la France même si Paris
assure officiellement que la question
des livraisons de gaz n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour libération qui s'est
rendue à Bab El Oued quartier populaire
mythique de la capitale Alger où il a
constaté que l'envoler des cours des
hydrocarbures ne semble pas beaucoup
profité à une population
frappée de plein fouet par la flambée
des prix et le taux de chômage près de
12% de la population Bab El Oued dont
certains habitants expriment dans
Libération un sentiment de rancoeur
persistant envers une France perçue
comme hypocrite et intéressé un
sentiment qui a d'ailleurs été exacerbé
depuis la réduction par deux le mois
dernier du nombre de visa accordé au
Marocain et aux Algériens qui a entraîné
une augmentation des traversées
illégales en Méditerranée
et elle a eu également ce matin et là il
y a cette réplique de Vladimir Poutine
après l'explosion samedi sur le pont de
Crimée la destruction de cette
infrastructure à la fois stratégique et
très symbolique déclenche la colère du
président russe qui dénonce on l'a
entendu un acte de terrorisme et
réplique à cette explosion par des
bombardements délibérés sur des zones
civiles de zaporigia c'est en tout cas
ce qui affirme la version britannique du
gratuit Métro qui parle d'au moins 13
morts l'explosion du pont de Crimée
inauguré on s'en souvient en grande
pompe par Vladimir Poutine en 2018 est
en revanche perçue côté ukrainien comme
une victoire éclatante sur le patron du
Kremlin comme en témoigne cette photo de
jeunes ukrainiennes posant devant des
photos du pont incendié à Kiev c'est à
la une du quotidien britannique de Times
ce matin Mediapart le site d'info
français par le lui d'un camouflet de
plus pour Vladimir Poutine à l'issue
d'une semaine qui vous qui devait
l'annexion des territoires occupés du
crâne avait dit mirent Poutine de plus
en plus contestée d'après le site
d'infos français 12 dessins de Davy row
qu'on a trouvé sur Twitter montrant le
président russe menacé par les flammes
du pont de Crimée le président russe
qu'on retrouve également dans ce dessin
de monter morline non seulement pour The
Times on voit les casquettes de ces
généraux soufflaient pas l'explosion du
pont de Crimée un dessin donc de moton
Molen pour The Times
vous allez nous dire un mot de cette
contestation toujours en cours en Iran
et de cette répression et de cette
réponse peut-être des écolières
désormais
station hier des colliers dans les
locaux même de leur école par des hommes
armés arrivant dans des fourgonnettes
sans plaque d'immatriculation le
quotidien britannique rapporte que les
autorités iraniennes ont annoncé hier
également la fermeture de toutes les
écoles et de tous les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur du Kurdistan
iranien dont était originaires on s'en
souvient à Marsa Amini dont la mort a
mis le feu aux poudres le journal c'est
notamment cette déclaration de la
ministre allemande des Affaires
étrangères
Analena berbock déclare que quiconque
des femmes et des filles dans les rues
enlèvent des gens qui ne veulent rien
d'autre que vivre librement et du
mauvais côté de l'histoire je les cite
l'histoire ou entrera peut-être ce
cliché
il a été pris le 3 octobre dernier à
Téhéran il a fait le tour du monde
depuis les jeunes iraniennes on le voit
brandissent un doigt d'honneur à
l'intention du Guide suprême iranien à y
ramener merci beaucoup Hélène frein